I have my real milk instead of oat milk
again so I'm back in a good
mood all
right so for today uh uh I asked you to
read the map ruce paper and so this is a
a bit of a shift in topic for us uh so I
want to try to before I jump right into
talking about map reduce I want to try
to to contextualize it a little and
relate it to things that we have been
talking about um so until now uh we've
been talking a lot about systems that uh
you make requests to and you get
responses from so the key value store
that uh you're implementing works that
way Dynamo works that way and a lot of
systems work that way so web servers
work that way uh databases work that way
[Music]
um whoops I have to fix one thing on
Zoom
here what do you see if you're on Zoom
right now can you see uh can you see my
paper
you have
OBS
okay one
second
fascinating all right how's this
all right I must have shared the wrong
uh
display sorry about that all right
onward so um yeah so as I was saying so
up until now um we've been talking
mostly about systems that to which you
make requests and receive responses um
so so the key value store that you've
been working on or any key Value Store
falls into that category um or web
servers or
databases uh
caches that might sit in front of web
servers or
databases all these things uh fall into
this category of systems to which you
make requests and receive responses um
so we can lump all these things together
under the term
services
or online
systems and uh note that some of these
things can be quite specialized right so
when you see web servers here uh you
shouldn't necessarily think just about
like a general purpose web server um
like Apache or engine X you should think
about something that like an app that
might have its own integrated web server
that's built specifically to serve only
that app uh so there's a lot of things
that fall into this
category um and what all these have in
common is that they wait for requests to
arrive from clients and then they try to
handle those requests quickly
quickly to the extent possible uh
quickly uh within the constraints of say
whatever consistency model that that
you're trying to guarantee and so on um
but low latency low latency is important
uh the time between when you send a
request and when you receive a response
availability is typically important
every qu every request receives a
response usually that's
important but this is not the only way
of Building Systems uh and there are
also systems that
uh that that take in a large amount of
data do something to process it and
produce some output data and this might
take quite a
while so that's a different kind of
system and we call these systems
batch processing
systems or offline
systems so the main performance
concerned with these kinds of questions
is not low
latency it's having high throughput so
the more data that you can process at a
time the faster that you can crunch
through a huge data
set that's the goal with these kinds of
systems batch processing systems so
which is map reduce is it an online
system or is it an offline
system right yeah it's an offline system
so although Google obviously runs a lot
of online systems too uh under the hood
the data that those systems are serving
up which might be search results or
videos and so on was most likely the
result of some large scale offline
distributed data processing
job so and typically that work would
have been done not necessarily by map
reduce more likely by A system that was
a successor of map produce um but
something that was in the spirit of map
produce often
um so map reduce falls into this
category and its
successors so map produce is old now uh
it's now 15 years old um it's no longer
the shiny new techn ology that it once
was um somebody just asked in chat so
map produce is dead uh so I would say
that it's it's not so much dead as there
are systems that now uh do the same
thing but but in a more General way uh
so there are system systems that
generalize map ruce the ideas are still
good uh but um but the system has been
has been subsumed by something that is
perhaps more general or smarter um so I
think it's still worth studying and
understanding the original map reduce
paper um one because it's a well-written
paper and it's a classic um and also it
it um it helps us see why and how batch
processing is important and useful um so
we're going to spend some time talking
about it okay so
um one thing that that we kind of didn't
have time to discuss last time when we
began to talk about sharding uh was
there's the notion that there might be
different ways to Shard your data uh
depending on how it's being
accessed um so we didn't really talk
about this um because we didn't
necessarily talk about data that's being
accessed in different ways we were just
talking about key value Stores um but
this is actually a very important
question because data might have
different access patterns depending on
what you want to do with it so we only
talked about this very simple data model
with keys and values but what if you had
a more
sophisticated data model uh and when you
have that the question of of how to
Shard the data becomes a lot more subtle
so what I mean by a more sophisticated
data model U might be what if you have a
relational database uh with kind of more
sophisticated relationships between
tables then the kinds of the the the way
that you Shard your data might depend on
what kind of queries you expect to do of
that data so for example uh people who
use Facebook the
website uh are accessing the data in one
way but if you're a data scientist at
Facebook who's trying to do analysis of
um of the Facebook social graph then
you're access accessing the data in a
different way so those two use cases
same data right same graph but very
different access patterns and so in the
end you might want to store your data in
multiple different data stores that use
different ways of representing and
sharding the data uh so technically that
would be redundant right because it's
the same underlying data but the
differing representations make a huge
difference to how long certain tasks
might
take um so a data science scientist
who's working at Facebook who's like
trying to analyze how users access the
site um that data scientist uh instead
of having that data scientist be sad
because their queries are always really
slow right um because they're not going
to make it slow for the regular user to
use the site
right um instead what they'll probably
do is have a redundant copy of the data
that's differently organized and that
copy will be specifically for the data
scientists to work
with so in the map reduce paper they
have names uh for these different
representations of data uh and they call
them raw data and derived
data so raw data is the authoritative
version of the
data when new data comes in uh it goes
into some form of raw data storage
and derived data is the result of taking
some existing data and transforming it
or processing it somehow
so derived data might come from raw data
or derived data might come from other
derived
data the most concise description of map
reduce that I can think of is map reduce
is a tool for computing derived data
so does anybody remember uh in the maap
r newspaper what is the first example
that they give of derived data
inverted indices yeah so I think yeah
they mentioned word count also that's
right um so the first I think end to-end
example that they give is a word count
example and that's a really good one um
we'll talk more about that U but even
before that um like uh like in sentence
one paragraph one um they talk about
this notion of an inverted Index right
so do you all know what an inverted
index is I think this term is a little
bit confusing uh so let's go over it
okay
so let's talk about search engine so a
search engine is trying to index
everything on the web right or as much
of it as it can um so the crawler goes
out and gets a whole bunch of
documents uh and we end up with a list
of documents
right so we have document
one do document
2 and so on and we have
words that are in those documents
and so
on so this is sometimes called a forward
index so this might be the data
structure that gets built as you crawl
the
web but is this data structure good for
doing queries like give me all the
documents that have the word fox in
them no it kind of sucks for that um
that would be really slow right if this
was how your data was organized so you
don't organize it this way or at least
you don't only organize it this way you
also build an inverted index uh which is
an an inversion of the forward index so
instead of having a list of documents
and for every document a list of the
words in it um an inverted index
is a list of
words and then for every
word uh the list of documents that it's
in um so the word the'
is in both document one and document
two
quick is only in document
one
growls is in document
two uh and so
on so now we have a data structure that
supports uh fast lookup by
word there's no more information in here
than there was in this one up here uh
it's a same
information uh but it supports a
different way of accessing the data
that's it that's all an inverted indexes
okay so how would you write a program to
turn the forward index into the inverted
index and this is not yet a distributed
systems question so forget everything
you know about distributed systems
forget replication forget partitioning
forget fall tolerance forget all that
stuff that we spent the first seven
weeks on um how would you write an
algorithm to turn this into
this so here's one thing we could
do all right yeah go ahead what do you
think
yeah okay okay so look through so we
have the forward Index
right we could Loop through all of the
documents in the forward
index what do we do for every document
we Loop over every word in it right and
we have to keep track of the word and
the document ID so
we might have something like
this for each
document in the forward
index and then for each word
so
first you're going to emit those pairs
of the word in the document so this
would be something
like
the doc
one
quick doc
one and so on and then the ones from
document two
the duck
to
dog and so on so that would be the
result of
this right and then what do you
do well what you want is something that
looks like this
right so you have to figure out how to
combine those pairs to get something
that looks like that so what you want to
do is you want to combine the documents
in a list for every unique
word
so you've got this list of key value
pairs right with some repeated keys
right some of the words are repeated so
now all you have to do is make it so the
keys are unique and squash down their
values to a list of values so you want
this to turn into something like
like
this and so on and then we have our
inverted
index so I think the name inverted index
is a little confusing because it's
really just like the index that you'd
see in the back of a book uh so it's a
list of words and for every word it's a
list of places that that word appears uh
we normally don't call that an inverted
index we normally just call it an index
but for people who make search
engines it's an inverted index because
it's an inversion of the forward index
uh that was made when they were scanning
the web okay
so would you say that the process of
creating this inverted index is
particularly complicated
conceptually when we leave aside all
that stuff that I said to forget about
um replication and fault tolerance and
partitioning and and all that and making
stuff go fast if you leave aside all
that was the algorithm for computing
this inverted index particularly
complicated no no it's pretty
straightforward I'm sure any of you
could write the code to do it uh easily
with no sweat so why are we even talking
about this why is this even a topic of
discussion in a distributed systems
class well because if you're doing it at
Large Scale then all that stuff that I
told you to forget about of replication
and fault tolerance and partitioning and
making sure it goes
fast when you're doing this at Large
Scale this becomes a distributed system
problem and you have to think about all
that stuff you have to think about fa
tolerance you have to think about
partitioning uh you have to think about
the stuff that this course is
about so the Insight of map reduce is
that the authors Jeff and Sanjay as well
as lots of other people they observed
that a lot of the computations that they
wanted to do were conceptually simple
like
this um but because they had to be done
on huge amounts of data in a distributed
fashion the Simplicity of the algorithms
was obsc cured by the huge amount of
complication of all the code that they
had to do to handle the distributed
system stuff so they they said wouldn't
it be great if there were a framework
that allows people to write these
conceptually simple algorithms and then
plug them into a system that hides all
of the distributed system stuff and
takes care of it automatically for them
that is what mece
is so for instance what if our forward
index here this thing that we're
operating
on what if it's too big to fit on one
machine as it of course is because it's
it's it's a forward index of every
document on the web so it's too big to
fit on one machine so some of our rows
are in on one machine and some are on
another machine some are on a third
machine and so on and let's also suppose
that the finished inverted index is also
too big to fit on one machine so that's
normal for a map reduced
computation um so what do you do let's
say that you're a machine and you only
have part of the forward
index so maybe you
have just for uh
for for the sake of
discussion let's say that you just have
this one
document how do you proceed what do you
do
can you do anything if you just have
that one document can you make any
progress so it turns out that you can so
you can just go ahead and compute Your
Word document pairs right you can do
this for the part of the input that you
are responsible for and other machines
can compute theirs for the part of the
input that they're responsible
for
so in other words
this part of the outer loop this Outer
Loop here this for each document uh this
could be done in parallel for all the
documents even if there were only one
document per machine that's not how it's
going to be it'll be like many documents
per machine um but it could be done in
parallel for all the
documents is there any dependency
between the different iterations of this
Loop that is do we care about what order
the iterations of this Outer Loop runs
in no there's no
dependency so they're completely
independent uh we call computations like
this embarrassingly
parallel that is to say it is so easy to
split up the computation into
independent parallel tasks that it would
be embarrassing not
to so there are a lot of things of
course that are truly very hard to
parallelize but this ain't one of
them okay so let's imagine that every
row of the forward index that is every
document is on its own machine so let's
draw a picture of what that would look
like
okay
let's say that we have three machines at
least
I don't actually have a dog More's the
pity okay so in this embarrassingly
parallel
computation each machine is going to run
the same function on its piece of the
forward
index uh and it's going to write the
results to its own local memory so no
communication between machines is needed
to do
this
so machine one will operate on the
document that it has and it'll create
these pairs of a word and a document in
this case all the all the documents are
going to be document one so it'll look
like and so on and Machine 2 will do the
same
machine 3 will do the
same the results of this computation are
called
intermediate key value
pairs intermediate because we're not
done yet right we still have to create
the the inverted index but this is uh
this is the the halfway done point one
important thing to point out is that
this all happens just on these local
machines so there's no communication
between the machines required to do this
and when they produce their output uh
they're not sending it to another
machine yet they're just writing it
locally so these are
all local
rights which means they're cheap nothing
has to be sent over the network to do
this okay
but we're not done right we want to
finish creating the inverted index so
what has to happen with the intermediate
key value pairs now if you have these
and what you want is something that
looks like
this where you have a list from word to
list of documents where that word
occurs somebody tell me what has to
happen with these intermediate key value
pairs
yeah we got to put them together somehow
well the ones with the same key have to
be combined right how are we going to do
that they're still on different
machines well let's say that we have two
machines for this second phase of the
computation
so what's going to be a good way to
split up the intermediate data onto
those two
machines as a hint uh we talked about it
a little bit last
time when we were talking about charting
yeah you're going to Hash the keys right
and do because we have two machines
we're going to do mod two of the hash or
in general if you have R machines for
this phase of the computation uh you can
take the hash of the keys mod
R so this if you do that that will have
the happy outcome of putting everything
with the same key on the same machine so
if these were the pairs that you ended
up with on your
uh on on these three machines um now you
have to move them to the machines where
they
belong um let's suppose that the keyth
hashes to machine
R1 so that means that both of these will
get will end up on machine
R1 so we'll have
the doc one
the doc
two um and let's say that dog hashes to
R1
also and probably some other stuff and
then maybe some other Keys hash to R2
and so on but we have this nice property
that uh everything that has the same key
and ended up on the same
machine now what do R1 and R2 have to do
with their data well they have they just
have to combine the pairs with the same
key so this turns
into and then down
here maybe we also had uh
something like that so we
get so that's it
so how did this data get onto R1 and r
to for them to be able to do this
computation well they had to get it from
those machines M1 M2 and M3
right so they had to get it from here
and this is a little bit annoying um
because take R1 for
instance
um which machines does it have to read
from well it has to read from all of
them right because all of them might
have the keys that are in the set of
keys that it's handling right um and
likewise R2 has to read from all of M1
M2 and
M3 so we have a communication pattern
that looks like this
so a read has to happen
here for all of
those or if you wanted to you could draw
the arrows the other way as well um now
fortunately once the data is actually on
R1 and R2 then they can communicate
independently from each other without
communicating but you do have to have
this all toall
communication uh this pattern is known
as a shuffle
so I call this a communication pattern
rather than a computation pattern
because no actual computation takes
place here it consists only of moving
data
around uh but this ends up accounting
for a large chunk of the time that it
takes to do these kinds of of map reduce
computations so computation happens
locally on M1 M2 and
M3 uh which we saw and then computation
happens locally on R1 and R2 uh which we
saw but then there's this middle phase
uh where no computation is happening but
data is just getting moved into the
place where it needs to be and I guess
we should draw these arrows both ways
because uh the read uh the data gets
sent to R1 R2
so shuffling is expensive it requires
sending a lot of data over the network
for the sole purpose of getting it into
the right place in order for the next
phase of computation to happen the good
news is that you can play tricks to
avoid having to shuffle so much data um
which we'll talk about a little bit next
time um but just uh just to make this uh
picture more obvious um let's let's uh
flesh out the details a little bit um so
we started with M1 M2 M3 um with our
documents over
here
so here's the local part of the
computation that happened on M1 for
example so that turned into
this and then similarly for M2
and so on so that's computation happen
happening locally on these machines um
then a whole bunch of data gets sent
over the network which is the
result of these
computations and then when it arrives
over here uh on these machines they take
the data that they got
and they operate on it locally to
produce the inverted index that we want
so there's the thing that we finally
wanted okay
so what have I left out here
well I talked about how the input was
too big to fit on one machine well the
output is also too big to fit on one
machine um what what's going to happen
with this data once R1 and R2 are
done what happens with
it well R1 and R2 have to write their
output
somewhere a Google what they do is they
write it to a distributed file
system
so that used to be something called GFS
or Google file system uh they have a new
one now but uh in this paper it's G GFS
so let's say GFS so R1 and R2 write
their output
onto
GFS so this might be like file
one and then you might have another
file that was the result of whatever R2
did
and that's it congratulations you know
map
reduce so we just walked through a
typical map reduce
computation um the part of the
computation that took place on these
machines over
here is known as the map
phase moving the data from the m
machines to the r machines is known as
the shuffle
phase and the part that took place on
the r
machines is the reduce
phase so this particular
example was an inverted index uh but it
turns out that this this pattern of map
phase Shuffle phase reduced phase is
common to a lot of
computations the only part of the
computation that was specific to this
particular task at hand was a tiny
little piece of code
right the the tiny little piece of code
that we kind of sketched out
earlier so
here's the tiny piece of code that was
specific to this
phase so that's called the map function
and then the tiny piece of of code that
was specific to the reduce phase um
would be something like combine the
documents in a list for every unique
word so everything else isn't specific
to this
task so what map reduce is is a
framework for doing these kinds of
computations in the map reduce framework
you plug in these two little pieces of
code which are known as the map function
and the reduce function I'll I'll try to
write down reduce function here um
so just so it's all on one
page so in order to use map reduce you
have to plug in these two tiny pieces of
code and the rest is handled for you by
the framework it will split up your
input data onto the M machines known as
the map
workers um you have to specify how many
you want maybe uh but it'll it'll split
them up for you it'll put your code on
all those machines so that your code
that you wrote can run on the data it'll
handle the shuffling for you so that you
get the correct intermediate key value
pairs onto these uh R machines known as
the reduce workers and it'll make sure
that the output of the reduced workers
ends up on a distributed file system uh
in the case of this paper
GFS and by the way everything on GFS
gets replicated so you actually use up
uh twice as much output storage as the
output that your computation produces if
your replication factor is two so it's a
lot of storage
space um so that's map reduce map ruce
uh
has a popular open- Source clone by the
way does anybody know what it's
called Hadoop yeah uh and of course map
reduce depends on the existence of
something like GFS so Hadoop has its own
clone of that too uh it's called hdfs
Hadoop distributed file
system okay uh let's pause and do a quiz
question and let's talk about the last
couple of quizzes
also okay so I don't think we talked
about this one yet um so the last couple
of quizzes this was uh this was from a
couple of days ago uh what problem does
the Dynamo paper use a gossip protocol
to solve uh what we were looking for
here was uh so we we talked about how
Dynamo uses gossip to um uh to
communicate between replicas to resolve
conflicts in the in the view of
membership so this is distinct from
resolving conflicts in the actual
application key value pairs that are
being stored this is for resolving
conflicts in the view of who's
participating in the system uh that's
what Dynamo uses gossip
for so that was that quiz um this one
from our discussion of partitioning uh
so what's the downside of using hash mod
n as a data partitioning strategy the
the the the downside is what if n
changes right so what if you want to add
or remove nodes from your system uh add
nodes to your system or remove nodes
from your system then all the data has
to move around now I just said that we
could use hash moden to partition the
data onto the reduce
workers uh and where we take the hash of
the of the key and um of those
intermediate key value Pairs and then
partition it onto the reduced workers so
that's okay in this context because you
don't expect the number of reduced
workers to change uh dynamically as your
map reduced job is running so this
actually works fine as a data
partitioning strategy in the use case of
map reduce uh but it doesn't necessarily
work fine uh if you're doing something
like Dynamo and you want to uh be able
to Dynam dynamically add and remove
nodes uh from the
ring uh so that's what we were looking
for there the downside is if n changes
then more data has to move around than
is uh than is actually
necessary all right so those were the
last couple of quizzes and here's
today
e e
it's funny last Friday when we were
using streamyard uh so streamyard
integrates nicely with twitch uh but it
also changed the category of my twitch
channel from I think I had it on science
and technology and it changed it to talk
shows and podcasts so it's still on talk
shows and podcasts so if anybody was
looking at the talk shows and podcasts
category on Twitch and was hoping for a
talk show I hope you enjoyed this Maas
lecture instead
maybe I can change that back
yeah okay so yeah a good question um
just asked uh on slack
so is map reduce mainly used for getting
inverted index in a distributed system
environment so map reduce is mainly used
for doing all kinds of
computations uh not necessarily inverted
index that's so this this uh this
example that we sketched out um
is uh it's a it's kind of a canonical
example of something that you would do
with map reduce uh and something that uh
the Google was very interested in doing
uh in an
efficient uh and and fault tolerant way
um but it's not obviously it's not the
only thing so map redu is is um allows
you to plug in any map function and any
reduced function that you want often
this is going to be something uh for
processing large amounts of text Data at
least if you're Google that's what it'll
be um so inverted index is is one thing
that you might do but it turns out that
a whole lot of common batch processing
tasks can fit into this map rued
programming
model um so let me wait a couple more
minutes uh for for quiz responses to
come in and then we'll keep talking
about
that e
all right
so let's continue
so like we just said it turns out that
that a lot of tasks can fit into the map
reduce programming model and the paper
gives a bunch of examples so in addition
to this word
count and uh inverted index
examples
uh distributed grap
distributed
sort and so
on so these are all computations that
can be
expressed in the map reduced programming
model
so you can think of the map reduce
framework as factoring out all the code
that's common to doing these
computations at large scale and making
it so that you don't have to manually
write that code so the only code that
you have to write is the map function
and the reduce function and if you can
figure out a way to express your
computation as those two functions then
and maybe you know some tuning
parameters that say something like how
many uh how many machines to use for
which phase the map phase and the reduce
phase and a little bit of code saying
where to find the input and where to
write the output on your distributed
file
system that's all you have to do and map
reduce will take care of the rest for
you um so what questions do people have
about this any questions so
far let me go back to CH here to see if
there were any questions I
missed yeah so so this is a key Point uh
being able to plug in code is is what
it's about uh and so arguably this is
this is what a framework is when
somebody talks about a a programming
framework as opposed to a library um so
a library sort of gives you a collection
of tools that you can or a collection of
pieces that you can assemble how you
want um a framework is more like here's
a a program with a couple of little gaps
in it and we want you to fill in the
gaps for map reduce you're filling in
the gaps with the map function and the
reduce
function and then that will kick off
this whole distributed fault tolerant
large scale computation in a data center
um so notice that like these these
computations are not necessarily things
that are that that would be hard to do
if you were doing them on one machine
right um the thing that makes them hard
is the fact that you're doing them on on
gigantic amounts of
data
um oh sorry somebody couldn't read this
this is the word grap here so so um
search uh uh like searching for for uh a
particular uh uh for for for Strings
that match a particular regular
expression let's say so this is this is
briefly me mentioned in the map reduce
paper okay so here's a
question when we were talking about
sharding uh we we talked about how you
know if you want to Shard onto end nodes
you can uh you can take the hash of the
key and then do mod end of that um well
we said the problem with that right was
if n changes then all your data almost
all of it has to move around
um and well and could change if you
decide you need more nodes to store more
data or handle more throughput um and
and could get smaller if nodes died
right um so we
suggested using instead of this hash of
hash of the key mod n we suggested using
consistent hashing right organizing the
nodes in a ring uh every node gets
hashed into a particular point on the
ring
and uh a and a node is responsible for
the keys that are in a given key range
on a certain piece of the Ring right and
when nodes join or leave it's only the
immediate neighbor that gets affected so
that's all great but in the map rce
paper they say it's fine to just use
hash of key mod
n and that's the very thing that we said
last time maybe wasn't the best idea so
why why is this okay to do in the
setting of map reduce
so here's our picture again
yeah so I would argue that in the
setting of map
reduce when you kick off a map reduce
job you know how much data you're
working with right um so it's not
necessarily going to be a dynamic amount
of data that's arriving right you have
in the case of in the case of the
inverted index example you have the
forward index you know how many
terabytes it takes up um and so you can
you can reasonably estimate how many
machines you're going to need you're not
going to run into a situation where
you're halfway through your map reduce
computation and you think oh no I have
to add another uh another machine here
in order to handle all the data now of
course you still have there's still the
possibility that that a machine can fail
right uh so map reduce has
accommodations for that so so map reduce
does checkpointing uh it has uh so so so
map reduces tolerant right you don't
have to start all over from the
beginning should there be a failure um
but you don't have to deal with this
situation of in like let's say in Dynamo
um you have your service that's up and
running accepting requests from clients
and all of a sudden you start getting a
certain kind of request that you didn't
necessarily anticipate so that isn't
going to be an issue uh in map reduce or
in or in offline systems generally uh
you know the computation that you have
to do and it's just a matter of doing
it
so next time we're going to look at more
examples uh and we're also going to talk
more about this question of fault
tolerance in map reduce and
optimizations um uh but
uh I want to I want to I want to point
out that um there's there's a few things
here that are that that I think are key
that you remember so one thing that's
key is that
these computations these rights right
here these are all
local
so when each of these map workers does
its computation it doesn't have to send
anything over the network initially when
it's Computing these intermediate key
value pairs um and the reduce phase each
of these reduce workers uh it's doing
its computation locally and it's then
storing it somewhere on the network so
there's a there's uh there's still
Network traffic that has to take place
when you're storing the data in its
final resting place on your distributed
file system um but importantly um each
of these map workers can work on its own
independently uh to produce this initial
set of of intermediate key value pairs
um so all of the uh all of the work of
sending things over the network really
happens in this Shuffle phase uh so so
the shuffle phase is the important part
uh in terms of network
traffic all right so we're almost out of
time for today
um uh next time we're going to look at
some other examples uh and we'll talk
more about this question of fault
tolerance um yeah let's wrap
up have a wonderful beginning of your
week